Speaker 1: Welcome back to the David Pakman
show. I am Ferron cousins from Ring of Fire.
Let's get back into some of the news of the
week. And one of the more interesting non
January six things that have happened this week
is that Marjorie Taylor GREENE has been suffering
basically a week long meltdown for so very
many different reasons. The first, of course,
is the fact that it was recently revealed that the
individual that has been defacing her transphobic
sign outside of her office turns out to be the
chief of staff to a Democratic representative.
And the Capitol Police were able to find this
individual. They put up, you know, security
cameras. They got him on camera. They referred
him for criminal prosecution. And the DOJ said,
yeah, we're not going to go after that. Which
honestly makes a lot of sense. This individual.
Sure. I mean, nobody should deface property and
make sure I'm crystal clear on that. Don't do it.
But it's always about, you know, writing on
somebody's side, like writing Bible verses,
putting stickers on it is what they did.
You really want to criminally prosecuted
somebody for that? I mean, you're talking about a
misdemeanor offense. You know, the value of which
is far less than anything that could even remotely
send somebody to jail. So you're mostly talking,
maybe giving them probation, maybe community
service, maybe. Again, we're talking about a
very minor misdemeanor, probably just a fine. And
Marjorie Taylor GREENE is, you know, basically
crying every day because the DOJ doesn't want to
spend thousands of dollars to prosecute somebody
for putting a couple stickers on her sign. And
of course, she's mad about Triumph, The Insult,
comic dog, Colbert's staff, you know, going in
and mocking her. And so she was given some time
this week on the floor of the House, which I don't
know why she was given the time, but she was given
the time. And she used it to paint herself as
the biggest victim that the United States has
ever seen. Here it is. Take a look at Marjorie
Taylor GREENE talking about how she is being
viciously attacked on all fronts. Here it is.
Speaker 2: I have come here as a freshman member
of Congress. And I want to remind everyone I have
never been arrested. I've always paid my taxes. I
have not broken the law. I have done nothing
wrong. It's the majority party that doesn't
like my speech. That's it. So I've been kicked
off committees. I've been routinely attacked.
I have been lied about. My character has been
completely destroyed not only by people in here,
but the media definitely helped some.
Speaker 1: Now, that was just a 32/2 clip
of Representative GREENE speaking on the House
floor about all these horrible things. She spoke
for an hour. Whining about how mistreated she has
been. She spent more than 10 minutes of that hour
talking about her poor little signs. And of
course, she claims that she was attacked because
the member of Congress across the hall put out a,
you know, LGBTQ flag. The idea was actually the
transgender flag. So that was an attack on her.
So she had to fight back by putting her little
transphobic sign out there. So she's just fighting
back. I got no sympathy for Marjorie Taylor
GREENE. You have not actually been attacked.
You've been mocked. You've been ridiculed.
Sure. But you deserved every second of it. You
want to talk about actual attacks? How about we
talk about how you have treated David Hogg, the
Parkland survivor? How you repeatedly harass him.
Are you still to this day harass him on Twitter?
Luckily. That young man is far more mature than
Marjorie Taylor GREENE could ever hope to be.
How about before you even came into office when
you were essentially stalking? Representative
AOC. And yelling through her mail slot in her
office. There's been reports of you, of course,
walking down the hallway screaming at Democratic
members of Congress. You know, we saw you the
one time Democrats doing the press conference on
the steps of the Capitol. You came out and you
started screaming at them. Those are attacks.
And you have the audacity to sit there on
the floor of the House of Representatives
and whine about a puppet. A
puppet trying to insult comic
dog as a puppet. And you were triggered
by the little puppet. It made you sad.
And then, of course, your sign, your poor little
sign. Oh, you have to keep sending your staffers
over to FedEx to make a new sign. Oh, dear me. How
do you even get up in the morning, Marjorie? My
goodness. Maybe take yourself down off of
that cross for a minute and look in a mirror.
You want to know why people are horrible to you,
as you say? It's because you get back what you
put in. You have done nothing to improve the
lives of anyone in this country. You have never
shown anyone any kind of basic niceties.
You have been mean. You have been a bully.
I mean, had you put out a video one time, you
were in the middle of a workout, you stopped
halfway through, pulled out your camera just to do
a short video telling Joe Biden he was a piece of
excrement and then you went back to your
workout. That's not even normal. Behavior
like that just goes beyond bullying to where I
would say that's almost a symptom, in my opinion.
But you can't treat the entire world like
garbage and then get mad when people dish it
back out to you. If you're going to deliver it,
you better learn how to take it. Or better yet,
maybe try being a decent human being for a few
minutes each day. See how that works out for you.
But honestly, I don't think you have it in you.